[音楽]
[拍手]
皆さんこんにちは
東京大学で
建築の研究をしている
森下優です
建築というと
建物のことを思い浮かべがちですが
自分は
建築を
様々なものやこと人の関係性
それを作るものだと考えていますこのよう
な
関係性について
理解を深めるため今月の半分ほど
北海道のフィールドで過ごしています
そこで行っている
自身の
研究活動を
再読
再び読む
英語でdvdingと
呼んでいます
再読とは
目の前のものを
当たり前だと思われていることを
改めて考えること
色々な思い込みをすべて削ぎ落として
そもそも
問うことを言っています
皆様が目の前のものと対峙するとき
多くの場合は
与えられた概念だったり人の頭の中で
すでに作られてしまった
そのような何かの構造を相手に当てはめて
ないでしょうか
本当に
相手のリアリティに
対峙して
会話ができているでしょうか
今日は
自分が
探索している研究のアプローチサイドック
するという行為について
江戸時間を再読することが
以下に建築たるのか
皆様と共有できたらと思います
これから
背景に移る画像なのですが
不快に思われる方がもういる可能性がある
と思いますそう思うかな蝦夷鹿熊と思う
場合はこれから目を閉じてお付き合い
ください
皆さんが
蝦夷鹿
シカと聞いて思い浮かべるのは何でしょう
か
僕が研究している北海道には予想時間が
あります
結構そこら中にいます
東京
都市では出会う機会が少ないと思います
食べること
ジビエを通してでしょうか
最近は
都内でもジビエを食べる機会が増えてきた
と思います
皆さんもどこかでジビエへ出会っているの
ではと思います
食べてますか好きですか
嫌いですか
今何を想像してますか高い
気象
美味しい
痩せ臭い
様々な連想がされると思います
ジビエという言葉が連想させるのは
様々あると思いますが
実際に食べてるのはかも
生地
イノシシしか熊この土地に生きる
者たちです
そもそもジビエこれはフランス語で
狩猟による食肉文化を表す言葉です
日本の人々が
野生の動物を食するという習慣を忘れて
しまった時代において必要とされたいわば
認知コミュニケーションですね
コミュニケーションの架け橋になった
言葉だと思います
ただ今日本で
ジビエジビエトを繰り返しているうちに
日本という土地に生きる者たちにあまり
馴染みのない海外の文化を重ねて考えてい
ないでしょうか
再読はちょっと待ったと一言発信この地に
実際に生きる者たちのことを考えます
それは
蝦夷鹿という相手のことを
自分の思い込みではなく
相手が生きる場所との関係性さらには
相手と自分が一緒に作っていくという関係
性の中から考えます今一度
欧州の食文化
予想時間
重なってしまっている状態から
掃除化というリアリティに戻してつまり
再読して
相手のことを考えてみたいと思います
相手蝦夷鹿のいるところその緑を置き現地
へ行けば
良いのかそう簡単ではありません
現地でも頭ごなしに
しかのことを理解する
構造これは同じです
北海道
十勝平野南部に自分の研究フィールドが
あります
東京から現地に行くと
蝦夷鹿児島はジビエではなく
酪農を含む農業
林業
いろいろな
業に対する害獣と呼ばれ
打たれそして補助金を得るために
スプレーで記録を取り
説法を切られ
捨てられる
存在です
本当に捨てられてるんですこれ北海道だけ
でなく
実は全国同じ構造ですこの外周という理解
は全国区
同じ解像度でしか
相手が見えてきません
打っておしまいなのでそこからは何の
新しい関係性も生まれません
現地では
外はそこに止まらず
悪い例では人里近くに鹿が捨てられてい
ますそれを食べに
ヒグマが現れる
ヒグマも害獣と呼ばれるようになりまた害
の枠がどんどん広がります
ヒグマが現れるので人間の
子供は
森に入ることがなくなり
森という空間が遠い存在になっていく
外の関係性は
広がるばかりです
また
補助金を巡って人と人の間のいざこざも
絶えずもうこれは蝦夷鹿の話ではないです
自分たちの自分の話人間の話になって
しまいました
農業という一つの
観点からいらないとされるものは語られ
ますが
蝦夷鹿の観点は少ない
それが今の現状です
人の営み
農業の観点が大切なのは
当たり前ですが
力が生きるのも当たり前
だとすると害だというのは思い込みでは
ないでしょうか
再読は現地に行くだけでは
終わりません
生きた蝦夷鹿の話をするにはどうしたら
良いでしょうか
僕が考える
再読のアプローチは
現地で頭だけで考えるのではなく
現場に入るそして
現物に
同時化の中に入ること
自身の手足を使って考える必要があります
相手の空間を理解することそれはどのよう
に作られていてそこにどのように自分たち
の空間と呼ばれるものを作っていくのかを
問いかけます
が走り抜ける牧草のあり方
悪の丘に聞き
酪農の空間の中に蝦夷鹿を探します
牧草地の向こうの
下半輪
トド松の職員そういう森があるのですが
森の研究者や
地域の林業に携わる方々に話を聞き
土地化の居住域である
森を育む管理する
計画する観点に触れ森という空間の時間の
流れ方を学びます
林業の中に映像時間を探し
自分たちが作る森がそして健在ともなる森
が
江戸時間の生態系を作っていることを学び
ます
漁師の方だと
農地や
森
防風林を歩き一緒に漁をするというよりは
蝦夷鹿の動き
広い
第一の植生の中を
蝦夷鹿がどう流れていってるのかその理解
に努めます
日高山脈から
山を伝え
川とその下半林を
通して
畑に流れてくる
蝦夷鹿の流れ
目の前の景色が
酪農の空間
林業の空間領の空間
蝦夷鹿の空間と重なり見えてきます
現場の理解から次は
現物と向き合い
実際に
掃除化の解体をここ1年ほど手伝い続けて
います
鹿の中から広がる関係性の角のつながりを
探します
研究を進めるにあたり
食肉加工士
シェフ
ペインターサウンドアーティストに
参加してもらい一緒に
十字化の理解に携わってもらいました
掃除化は食料としての糧だけではなく
考える過程でもあることが見えてきます
様々な観点から
存じかに入ることで
普段捨てられている部位を余すことなく
食する当たり前と
郷土料理としての可能性が見えてきます
エゾシカを打った際の
着弾を
[拍手]
この音を録音しに行くと音を聞くという人
の認知のありように
新しい
着眼点が生まれそして
蝦夷鹿の治療を用いて
インターは
現地の機会市に
絵を描きました
楽の
旗作林業食おと認知科学アート教育
蝦夷鹿をその命を余すことなく
考える糧とする日々は続きます
そこには
すでにいつも存在していたけれども
顕在化してこなかったものがありますこれ
まで
肉は捨てられ音は効き過ごされ
血は土に流れるのみ
それらの命は存在していませんでした
農地へ森へ下半輪へ
鹿の中へ外へつながる関係性のつながり
打った映像時間を捨てるとそこで関係性は
終わります
鹿には入れません
捨てないということが関係性を切らないと
いうことが
命のつながりを人の繋がりを生みます大切
にするという行為の集まりコミュニティが
エゾシカのことを考え始めます
話を聞き
足を運び手を動かすことで見えてくるのは
都会のジビエも現地の
害獣駆除もそれはどちらも命を取る話で
終わっていたということです
そこに命をつくる話
命と共に生きる話は聞こえてきません
漁師というと
命を取る仕事と捉えられがちですがある
漁師さんからは
取る命の数が重要なのではなく
打たないという判断をする
漁師が存在でき
蝦夷鹿と森と
農地と人の関係性を作っていく役割の一人
として量子が
存在する
その関係性の中で十字化の命のことを
考えることが必要なんだそう教えてもらい
ます
別の領主は
命を取る人が増えるそういうことよりも命
を取ることを理解する人が増えてほしい
そう言います
両親になる人よりも
漁師と一緒に山に入り山のありを社会との
つながりを理解しその関係性の延長にある
蝦夷鹿児島の命について
社会の一部として考えるそういう人が増え
てほしい
このように多くの
多様な方が
登場し
蝦夷鹿の関係性の健在化は
ジビエや
害獣そういう言葉からはたどり着けてこ
ないところが見えてきました
目の前のものを蝦夷鹿に戻してそして
生かして
初めてつながりが持ち始まります
このように見えてきた蝦夷地下とその関係
性を前にして
具体的に何を持って自分たちは建築するの
でしょうか
相手を自分の牧草地や
森の教会から中に入れない
関係性例えば柵を作るであったり
ボーダーコントロールをする場合
建築の材料は木材であったり
電線
有刺鉄線だったりします
そしてこの建築自分はいいんですけども
隣人の牧草地にゾシカは流れていき隣人と
トラブルになります人のいるところから
へそ時間を
完全に排除するまで
終わらない
建築の態度です
そうではなく今回見えてきたのは
相手との柔らかいコーラスな
動的なバランスを作る関係性も
建築しうるそういうことだと思います
銃声の音人の活動の音
すなわち物理的な周波数それがエゾ仕方の
距離
空間教会を作る
実際の材料となります
蝦夷鹿を考えそして必要とする
コミュニティが
教育イベント
例えばですがなので
森に集まりますそうすると人の匂い
化学物質が森につくことで人の空間を
主張する材料になります
また森の育成という長い時間枠の造作それ
は道の付け方であり
食事と手入れのサイクル
森とどのように関わるかという計画が蝦蔵
の流れ方を左右する材料となりますどれも
人がいないと始まりませんが人がいてこそ
人がいてこそ生きた建築が生まれるのだと
考えてます
この土地の生きる材料の関係性を
再構築して人も蝦夷鹿も存在できる空間が
建築できるのではと今ようやくスタート
地点が見えてきました
すなわち
有刺鉄線ではなく音
香り人
時間が自分たちの空間を建築を作る
材料となることの可能性をこれから
探求し始めます
冒頭に自分は
建築を様々なものやこと人の関係性を作る
ことだとお伝えしましたそれは
空間を媒体にするも建物に頼らないことも
あります
蝦夷鹿を
再読することでこれまでとは異なる材料で
建築を考えるきっかけになっています
また
蝦夷鹿を食べることは掃除化との多様な
関係性の中で生じるこの場所に生きる人々
の文化の一部でもあることに気がつきます
フランス文化をかぶっていた映像化
ガイとして悪者だった映像時間
少しは生きる映像時間が
垣間が見えてきたでしょうかそして
生きるものたちのための建築
建築自体の考え方が広がるのではない
でしょうか
人がくまなく
設計して作られた都市は頭で考え抜かれた
当たり前で満ち溢れています
しかしそんな当たり前の中では
存在できなくなってきてる命が
多々あります
もう
目を開けても大丈夫だと思いますサイドは
物事に
問いかけるだけでなく
テーブルの上のアイデアを書きますだけで
はなくて
実際にそのものたちが生きている
存在する現地へ現物へそして
現物とともに改めて考える活動ですより
多くの者たちが生きるそのような社会に
向けて
皆さんも明日から
再読しませんか
目の前の当たり前を
ありがとうございました
[拍手]